my name is Ronnie Hobbs I'm the
marketing manager at gun media you
taking a look at breach and clear
deadlines this is a spin off of the
original breaching clear not a true
sequel the original breaching clear with
a hybrid turn-based so it sparked
turn-based part build time strategy game
your plate is a real Special Operations
Forces team you're eliminating
terrorists around the globe it was a
hardcore strategy title meant for
hardcore military fans it was also built
on mobile so the somewhat casual so now
use these the same guys from breaching
play original saying Special Operations
Forces guys we're not revealing too much
about the story but you are found
yourself battling a monstrous parasite
parasitic worm that is overtaking a city
for a reason which we haven't discussed
yet so here you are to send a overview
one of our hubs which is really just a
zone of Arbor City which is very much
like Boston so you're here watching it
street-level and what you what he's
doing now is very reminiscent of what
you can do in the original breach and
clear which is he's in command mode
right now but any point in the game you
can tap L bothering will bring up
command mode and based on what you've
unlocked and what class your character
is you now have abilities that you can
use freely loading so that time he just
simply ordered his guys to just spread
out and do a flanking maneuver oh
they're here as you can see he stumbled
upon a horde and it looks pretty Bish's
and we have some black inspectors you
can't really tell what he's in store for
but he's sent him one guy to lay a mine
right here in this final position while
he sends the rest guys to cover which
was a huge part of the original region
clear so that's going to play out here
too for a second right now time is
almost stopped it's very very slowly
moving right now so you're pretty safe
believe it or not our fans are
constantly asking for Tom B's and you
wouldn't think that they would but
apparently people don't get tired of
zombies you know even in this day and
age there's been a million zombie games
but people still are infatuated with
that so ours are actually monsters as
opposed to zombie says we did a lot of
research on we saw a video of a
parasitic worm that I'm sure you made in
this video I don't know it overtakes
this praying mantis
it's a scariest thing we've ever seen
literally because it really exists we
have two options we have normal mode
which is no no permit
let me how about farming that motor so
in Parma death mode if you love your
guys to level 25 he's named after your
best friend he dies he's gone
you have to find a survivor which we'll
talk about here in a few minutes to
replace your team in normal mode that is
getting capacitated and they're down and
out and when you get back to a safe hub
like a safe house you can bring them
back into the fight so we wanted to
provide that super hardcore option for
perma death if you wanted right now he's
picking up ammo and if you notice he's
stumbled in off the street it was pure
blackness he couldn't really tell what
was inside the building toy got it here
sometimes that will get you in trouble
if you start exploring places maybe you
shouldn't be or you're you're not
leveled up enough so if you notice here
here's another aspect of the region
pretty clear he's going to put a
breaching charge on that door now what
happens is it's super noisy so he could
have potentially alerted all azam bees
in the area to this explosion it's what
he's gonna do now which is another cool
part of command mode is he's going to
split the team up he's insane two guys
in here to explore potential loot items
in here while he sends two guys back to
the first room to guard the doorway so
once again this is a very very
reminiscent of the original breaching
clear their high-level strategy thing
that you would do if you're in the
Special Operations but it just makes
sense in this game as well you know
something you would really do in real
life if this had happened you would want
to be very careful about what you're
doing so the hordes rushing in you can
on the fly just put the d-pad change
characters you can become any one of the
four characters and you can control them
instantly so if you don't feel the
computer or the AI is doing what you
want to do you just switch over and each
of the of the four guys is a different
class so those are classes that you'll
create and then you'll unlock abilities
because they all have their own skill
tree so there's like a breach where
there's a scout there's a medic that the
fireteam leader all those have their own
options he'd found a loot so these are
for weapons since we're not going to
show you the menu yet today you'll be
able to those will be random loop like
in fours or other weapons that are
potentially stronger than when you have
very Borland's desk so but what's cool
is though we still kept the the breach
and clear name pretty pretty good that
when all these weapons are authentic
now you will stumble upon like the
occasional shotgun or something that
it's like a hunting shotgun like really
really what you would find in real life
if some guy
add in his house if this situation
actually occurred so there's a couple
casual guns they're mixed in with our
hardcore military ones you also have
melee items so it's not as crazy as Dead
Island or Dead Rising so it's not like a
chainsaw on a paddle but yeah it's more
you know machetes and axes that you
would find laying around that helps you
take the stealth approach we had talked
about command mode being very available
all the time and only available
sometimes but right now we're coming
right right in the middle we're trying
to balance that gameplay wise what feels
is right now having it at your disposal
all the time really actually makes it
more strategic because you can always do
something whereas if you waste it you
know you can't do it again
so if you notice right now he's fighting
against humans these are can be anyone
who happened to you know think the
Grohl's ending which it is so they grab
arms and they set up their own little
man area here and they're fighting you
and they don't know who you are you know
they don't know you're the good guys so
not only are you going to run up on
monsters who have different levels of
you know they evolve basically you're
also battling humans which is very
reminiscent of reaching clear so there's
a lot of strategy here so he what he did
earlier he just now he used suppression
which is a ability he unlocked on his
command will so he suppressed these two
guys why he sends his other team members
around so you have to worry about
monsters and then you have to worry
about humans as well on our game so
that's the demo what we have we've been
developing this game for about two and a
half months so we're really very early
on it's going to be coming to early
access this fall probably our August or
September we plan on having a lot of the
basic framework there so a lot of a lot
of the zones that we're having the final
game will be available there a lot of
the classes and a lot of the loot system
and the procedural dungeons and most of
the game will be finished so we're going
to use the community to input their
ideas and see if we can actually put
them side of the game and the final
release date will be determined by how
much content we put in in early access
so if the community has all these great
ideas and everyone loves it then we have
no hard deadline for getting this game
out no pun intended
you